[Aplausos]
[Música]
ultraderecha y alemania son dos términos
que causan auténtico terror cuando van
juntos en la misma frase de hecho aunque
angela merkel haya vuelto a ganar las
elecciones por un margen bastante
aceptable la victoria ha dejado un sabor
agridulce
[Música]
el hecho de que alternativa por alemania
un partido xenófobo y de ultraderecha
haya quedado como tercera fuerza en el
parlament o es razón suficiente para
quitarle el sueño a la canciller
no vamos a dar excusas está claro que
queríamos un resultado mejor en visual
político teníamos pensado empezar esta
semana con un vídeo explicando por que
merkel ha ganado las elecciones en
alemania sin embargo hemos pensado que
lo mejor era posponer la publicación del
vídeo un día más para poderos hablar de
este otro partido político alternativa
por alemania o por sus siglas la ad ft
[Música]
y si ya sé lo que estáis pensando
fonseca como te puede sorprender que la
extrema derecha haya entrado en el
parlamento alemán a fin de cuentas en
casi todos los países de europa hay
partidos xenófobos con bastante fuerza
por otra parte a efe ya había cosechado
buenos resultados en las últimas
elecciones locales sin embargo casi
todas las encuestas apuntaban a que los
alemanes apreciaban la moderación mucho
más que los ciudadanos de ningún otro
país
[Música]
por ejemplo en francia el 50 por ciento
de los votantes se sitúa en el centro en
alemania sin embargo esta cifra llega o
llegaba al 76% por otra parte el país de
angela merkel apenas sufrió la crisis
económica es más su economía pasa por
uno de sus mejores momentos los sueldos
están subiendo prácticamente rozan el
pleno empleo y las empresas exportan el
mundo entero como si no existiera mañana
[Música]
quienes han votado a la extrema derecha
alemana y lo que es más importante que
es y que propone alternativa por
alemania de verdad estamos hablando de
un partido de extrema derecha o sea los
medios que están exagerando hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
un partido político dividido es cierto
hoy en día alternativa por alemania es
un partido populista cuya principal
propuesta es el rechazo a los refugiados
ya los inmigrantes sobre todo los que
vienen de países musulmanes sin embargo
sus orígenes son totalmente distintos
hablamos del año 2013 por aquel entonces
todos los medios de comunicación
europeos hablaban de la crisis de la
deuda en españa italia y sobre todo
grecia
para los que no conozcáis bien esta
historia os hago un resumen antes de la
crisis de 2008 los bancos alemanes
habían invertido en dar préstamos a los
gobiernos y las empresas del sur de
europa después de esta crisis financiera
de 2008 esos países no sólo no podían
devolver sus deudas sino que además
necesitaban pedir aún más dinero
prestado para seguir pagando sus gastos
corrientes' los sueldos de los
funcionarios el mantenimiento de los
hospitales las carreteras etcétera
lógicamente esta situación era
insostenible
así que angela merkel dijo vale os vamos
a prestar más dinero incluso os vamos a
dejar que nos lo devolvamos poco a poco
pero tenéis que reformar vuestros países
seguro que los que veáis este vídeo
desde españa ya sabéis a lo que me
refiero efectivamente estoy hablando de
la famosa austeridad es decir alemania
junto a otros países del norte de europa
quería prestar dinero a cambio de que
españa italia y grecia recortaron sus
gastos para que no necesitarán más
préstamos en el futuro y pudieran
devolver lo que ya debían sin embargo en
estos países del sur de europa estas
condiciones se vieron como un auténtico
asalto a la soberanía nacional quien se
cree que es alemania para decirnos cómo
debemos gastar nuestro dinero
[Música]
mientras tanto los alemanes le decían a
merkel y quien nos manda a ayudar a
otros países
olga que esto es la unión europea no una
ong
entre esos alemanes estaban este grupo
de economistas alexander gaula ver luque
y conrad hagan estos fueron los
creadores del partido alternativa
electoral 2013 que después se
convertiría en alternativa por alemania
[Música]
y muchos de los creadores de este
partido venían de trabajar en bancos
universidades y empresas sobre todo de
la parte occidental de alemania ciudades
como frankfurt colonia o bon quedaros
con esto porque es muy importante en su
programa electoral
decían que alemania tenía que abandonar
el euro y volver al marco alemán porque
os preguntaréis bueno primero porque así
evitaban rescatar a esas economías
pobres del sur de europa segundo porque
así protegían la economía alemana de una
más que posible devaluación del euro
como os decíamos en este otro vídeo
alemania debe su riqueza en buena medida
haber tenido siempre una moneda fuerte
tanto grecia como 'españa estaban
presionando para que el banco central
europeo- imprimiera más billetes con los
que pagar sus deudas lógicamente esta
idea sonaba bastante mal para muchos
economistas y por eso los primeros
votantes de alternativa por alemania
tenían muy poco que ver con esos
hooligans de extrema derecha que podemos
imaginar eran empresarios y economistas
y profesores universitarios
y se explica porque los medios les
llamaban el partido de los profesores y
porque en esas elecciones federales de
ni siquiera consiguieran sacar un solo
diputado pensadlo bien la política
monetaria no es precisamente el tema más
sexy para un programa electoral sólo los
suscriptores de visual polític nos
preocupamos por estas cosas
sin embargo el destino de alternatiba
por alemania cambió en julio del año
2015 hasta entonces el economista ver lo
que había sido el presidente del partido
y la nueva lideresa frauke petri tenía
unos planes muy distintos
[Aplausos]
de entrada a diferencia de la antigua
cúpula directiva petri venía de la
antigua alemania del este y trae una
cultura política muy distinta para ella
todos esos temas de política monetaria
déficit y irresponsabilidad fiscal no
eran tan importantes era consciente de
que había un nicho de votantes
insatisfechos que estaban más
preocupados por otras cosas como los
inmigrantes o la identidad alemana
[Aplausos]
con este tipo de propuestas además se
ganaba la simpatía de varios líderes
internacionales como el británico nigel
farage del ukip la francesa marine lepén
del frente nacional y como no nuestro
gran amigo la mascota de visual política
el hombre que no podía faltar en ninguna
fiesta
la lideresa del partido de extrema
derecha alemán se reúne con putin en
moscú
[Música]
sí sé que hablamos mucho de vladimir
putin en este canal pero es que es
imposible resistirse
todo esto coincidió con la llegada de
miles de refugiados de siria irak y
libia
merkel les estaba recibiendo con los
brazos abiertos y muchos alemanes no
estaban tan contentos con estas
políticas así que en las elecciones
regionales de 2016 alternativa por
alemania se presentó con un programa
totalmente distinto a lo que habían
propuesto sus fundadores eso explica por
qué muchos de estos economistas
abandonaron el barco entre ellos el
mismísimo verne luque quien fue su
primer presidente
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y este partido ha caído
irremediablemente las manos equivocadas
desde entonces alternativa por alemania
tiene dos facciones enfrentadas por un
lado están los remanentes del núcleo
fundador pero cada vez son menos en su
lugar la mayor parte de los miembros han
llegado bajo la batuta de fraude petri
esto se traduce en muchos más votos pero
también en muchos más quebraderos de
cabeza
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la actual crisis de alternatiba por
alemania comenzó a mediados de enero con
el discurso rompe tabúes del radical vio
que que en un mar de dresde impidió que
alemania dé un giro de 180 grados a su
política de recordar y expiar por su
pasado nazi por muy partido de extrema
derecha que seas este tipo de cosas no
están bien vistas en alemania y por eso
la señora petri ha tenido más de un
problema incluso tiene una investigación
pendiente porque al parecer algunas de
sus propuestas podrían chocar con la
propia legislación alemana que intenta
prevenir el regreso de un posible
partido nazi los problemas en este
partido son tales que justo un día
después de las elecciones prop petri ha
abandonado el partido por desencuentros
con otras facciones aún más radicales
sin embargo pese a las salidas de tono y
la división interna
alternativa por alemania ha sido capaz
de dar la sorpresa en estas elecciones y
la pregunta es quiénes les han votado
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
las dos alemanias en los últimos años la
economía alemana está on fire los
sueldos crecen las empresas exportan y
la desigualdad es casi inexistente bueno
esto último es discutible si vale es
cierto que apenas hay pobreza en las
calles y que el tejido productivo se
reparte por todo el país pero si miramos
la distribución de la renta por regiones
vemos una división muy clara
[Música]
si os fijáis en este mapa veréis que hay
una parte roja y una parte azul la parte
azul es la más rica la parte roja es la
más pobre la parte azul corresponde a lo
que en su día era la alemania occidental
y la parte roja corresponde a lo que en
su día era la alemania del este la
alemania comunista esa alemania que se
pasó al capitalismo en 1989 pero que
todavía no ha llegado a disfrutar del
mismo nivel de vida que sus vecinos del
oeste
[Música]
si tenéis la ocasión de visitar una
ciudad como dresden en el este de
alemania veréis que todavía está llena
de grúas y obras casi todos los
edificios están construidos hace muy
poco tiempo y eso indica una cosa el
proceso de reunificación aún no ha
terminado
[Música]
por supuesto si comparamos el nivel de
vida de un alemán oriental con el de un
griego o un español no parece que les
vaya tan mal pero los alemanes se
comparan con sus ciudadanos y ahí sí que
salen bastante mal parados por supuesto
si comparamos el nivel de vida de un
alemán oriental con el de un griego o un
español no parece que les vaya tan mal
pero los alemanes se comparan con sus
ciudadanos y ahí salen bastante mal
parados
y no tiene suficientes oportunidades
industriales y no tiene suficientes
instalaciones educativas apropiadas un
centro cultural y deportivo son todo lo
que hay para que la gente disfrute de su
ciudad el centro de la ciudad está
mortalmente tranquilo y muchos jóvenes
emigran a las grandes ciudades del oeste
concretamente en esta ciudad en la
ciudad de shrek es uno de los lugares
donde alternativa por alemania- ha
sacado más de uno
por ciento de los votos y un poco más
abajo en el estado de baja sajonia la
extrema derecha ha sido la fuerza más
votada pero esperad un momento porque no
sólo hablamos de economía
hablamos de una cultura política
totalmente distinta pensadlo bien los
alemanes del este han vivido
generaciones enteras con un sistema
político totalmente distinto eso
significa una educación distinta un
estilo de vida distinto y unos valores
distintos en estas regiones la
moderación no es precisamente un valor a
tener en cuenta de hecho el partido de
extrema izquierda y el link que cosecha
muchos de sus votos en los barrios de
berlín que estaban en la parte este del
muro no sólo eso mientras los alemanes
occidentales se pasaron décadas
recordando su pasado nazi el gobierno de
la república democrática de alemania se
dedicó a crear un nuevo sentimiento de
orgullo
[Música]
así que cuando uno de los candidatos de
a efe dice por ejemplo que hay que
reconocer la valentía de los soldados
alemanes durante la segunda guerra
mundial en colonia se echan las manos a
la cabeza mientras que el later dicen
war o vale pero sin duda alguna hay una
pregunta aún más importante porque en el
este de alemania están tan en contra de
los inmigrantes y los refugiados muchos
pensaréis que es porque están hartos de
convivir con tantos musulmanes que no se
quieren integrar pero aquí os voy a dar
una cifra que romperá los esquemas
[Música]
de los más de 9 millones de inmigrantes
que hay en alemania ni siquiera medio
millón vive en el este como os podéis
imaginar la mayor parte de los
extranjeros que se marchan a alemania
eligen las regiones más ricas así que
encontrarse a una mujer cubierta con un
hiyab en las calles de dresden es
bastante poco común es más a que no
adivinan cuál es el principal grupo de
inmigrantes que hay en alemania del este
efectivamente los rusos más de la mitad
de los inmigrantes que viven en esta
zona vienen del país del vodka la
balalaika y vladimir putin y por
supuesto son el mayor nicho de audiencia
de rusia today en alemania y eso explica
cosas como estas
alianza por alemania despliega dos ejes
de campaña para atraer a los votantes
ruso alemanes así que ahora la pregunta
es creéis qué alternativa por alemania
puede seguir cosechando votos en las
próximas elecciones alemanas o las
divisiones internas acabarán con ellos
qué papel pueden jugar en la próxima
legislatura podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios mientras
tanto si queréis saber por qué alemania
es la fábrica del mundo hacer clic en
este vídeo y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]